Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg accused of
quote caving to pressure after charging
a marine veteran with second-degree
manslaughter Daniel Penny turning
himself into police today after the
Chokehold death of Jordan Neely on the
New York City subway that comes as a
brand new witness steps forward to give
a firsthand account of what happened on
that train a 66 year old woman backing
up several witnesses who saw Neely
making aggressive threats towards Riders
telling the New York Post that Neely
said things like quote I would kill a
mother effer and don't care I'll take a
bullet I'll go to jail she also went
back to thank Daniel Penny after the
incident the Marines attorney speaking
out and defending their client
this morning Daniel Penny surrendered I
had the fifth Precinct at the west of
the New York County his attorney's
office he did so voluntarily and with
the sort of dignity drop it bro that is
characteristic of his history of service
to this Grateful Nation yes
Neely has an extensive criminal history
he had been arrested 44 times including
for punching a 67 year old woman in the
face and for trying to kidnap a
seven-year-old girl he was also on New
York City's top 50 list of homeless
people who needed urgent help Neely's
attorney arguing today that none of that
should matter
no one on that train
ask Jordan what's wrong
how can I help you no one said
here you are sir
let me meet your need or help you in a
situation or give a word of
encouragement Daniel penny
did not know Jordan nearly before this
incident
that means Daniel Penny did not know how
many times he was arrested so that's a
non-factor so for anyone to bring that
up and say it impacted the situation
you can't do it
all right judge I want to come to you
first on this
um that way actually he's been charged
where does the case stand what are your
thoughts well
um first of all the judges indicated
that penny has to come back to court on
July 17th the grand jury will have
returned a decision one way or the other
a true bill or no bill depending upon
what happens but during this period of
time the defense now has an opportunity
and can demand that their client uh
testify in the grand jury the defense
will also be gathering their own
witnesses that they can present in the
grand jury they will also I'm sure get a
medical examiner I think that the
decision by this medical examiner was
where the quick uh and having been in
criminal justice and law enforcement for
32 years I can say that as a fact I also
think that the grand jury will have the
ability to make a better assessment than
Alvin Bragg did it was a knee-jerk
political leftist Progressive reaction
which we know Alvin Bragg is capable of
and more than willing to do the fact is
that Daniel Penny here stayed when the
police came they put them in a recovery
position he stayed to talk to the police
he then went down to the precinct to
talk to the police the police did not
make an arrest there was no arrest made
and then all of a sudden after everybody
starts rioting and demanding that
somebody be arrested yeah Alvin Bragg
says oh I'm going to charge him with the
felony complaints uh I don't know how
this will end but what I can tell you is
that if you're in a subway car and
you've got a guy yelling I don't care if
I spend my life in prison I don't care
if I die that means two things that
means he's willing to commit suicide or
homicide if he says I'm willing to go to
jail for Life the the only thing you
could go to jail for in life was
homicide and I'm willing to die I'm
suicidal now he wants to say they didn't
know he had 42 or 44 arrests I mean you
know that certainly is a good point
let's be fair about that but at the same
time his behavior there in that car
Underground when no one could get off
well no one had the ability to run away
makes it very clear that that the people
there as long as they are reasonable in
their assessment of the fear then they
can use whatever force is reasonably
necessary
okay
um will you're also a lawyer what do you
make of the odds of the self-defense
defense working out in this case and
what impact this eyewitness and I assume
there will be more that will end up
coming forward yeah the eyewitnesses
that are so far praising Daniel Penny to
the judge's point on the reasonable
standard if they have a jury or a grand
jury of people who have ridden the New
York City Subways then I think my
estimation is they'll come back with the
correct assessment that this was not
just reasonable Behavior by Daniel Penny
but potentially heroic Behavior by
Daniel Penny our society to be
absolutely clear needs more Daniel
pennies this if you have ridden the
Subway at any point or attempted to
raise children in this city and I did
for the first half of my children's life
you are very familiar with this knife's
edge razor moment of will this burst
into volatile violence every single
person in the city if you've ridden the
subway knows that experience Daniel
Penny stepped up we did see a security
guard in Allen Texas do the same thing
and stop what could have been worse
Carnage we would hope somebody would
step up even sooner we now need in lieu
of of prosecutors who fail to hold
people accountable citizenry that is
willing to hold bad people to account
now what Neely did or what he would have
done that day we will never know but we
do know his past and we have all been in
this situation and the end results of
this has to be more not necessarily
we'll all find the facts a jury will
decide the culpability but in general as
an instinct in this Society we need more
Daniel pennies well that's interesting
Katie because will is drawing the line
between how Daniel Penny acted and
vigilantism which we talk a lot about
because this the argument would go if
Daniel penny is found to have been
heroic in this and a lot of the videos
certainly indicates that he was that he
wasn't someone who just wanted to take
matters into his own hands there was a
real threat and he answered the call
what do you think the implications of
this going to trial playing out is going
to be on how people behave in public
transportation just walking down the
street yeah Daniel Penny didn't get on
the subway hoping this would happen to
him
the social justice mob has come after
him through Alvin Bragg he shouldn't be
charged he's being charged Jordan Neely
when he decided to get on that train and
start making those violent threats died
as a result of his actions and the
choice that the mob and Alvin Bragg have
asked Daniel Penny to make was to sit by
and watch as this guy ran through the
train threatening violence and violence
happens very quickly and we I do know
that this guy has a record of hitting
elderly women in the face which couldn't
be fatal now they had a warning so the
choice that they are asking Daniel Penny
to make is to sit back and watch
something horrific happen to someone
which he had done before
and you asked how we got here you asked
about vigilantism they defunded the
police and now they're going after
people who dare not to just defend
themselves but to defend others and the
further they go down this road of not
putting these criminals in jail letting
them out this could have all been
prevented by the way if Alvin Bragg kept
this person in jail or in treatment
the more intense the response is going
to be based on human nature and then the
final thing I just want to say is the
the portrayal of the the media has done
for Jordan Neely is just appalling I
mean this guy the photos of him being
Michael Jackson and dancing are from
2011. okay that was more than 10 years
ago that's what the media is portraying
this as they're not portraying it as a
violent criminal who's on the subway
with intention to hurt others and
someone having to step in and having to
make the horrible choice to do this and
now he's being persecuted for it and
while they won't you know perp walk
people like Jordan melee they'll perp
walk Daniel penny with the cops and make
sure all the cameras see it so the Alvin
Bragg can appease the social justice mom
Craig I do find it interesting in the
last 24 hours we certainly haven't seen
as much of the Daniel Penny as a
murderer or this was a lynching it seems
like the conversation around it has
calmed down a bit
um and I don't think that I'm in crack
that we haven't heard from AOC today or
Ayanna Presley who were very quick to
jump in there what do you think that
means about the case well I do think
that there's another silence going on
and it happened before this news broke
which was the protest stopped so there
was definitely collusion going on
between the Alvin brags of the world and
the protesters on the street that's the
new variable that you talked about how
mob can put their thumb on the scale and
actually influence the justice system I
want this this is a sham he never should
have been arrested I hope the guy gets a
fair trial but as long as you have a mob
there ready to intimidate you whether
you're a jury or a D.A or whatever
they're going to do it and that's what
they have been doing this I want to just
to summarize the story leaving out one
variable mentally deranged violent felon
menacing passengers on a subway a strap
hanger steps in a prevents an assault
gets help from others they then they
they get the guy into a a recovery
position people thank him
the variable that's left out is race
because race doesn't matter this guy uh
could have been Norwegian uh the the
dead man could be Norwegian but his
inclination for violence which is
obvious if you ride the subway uh you
don't need to know he had 44 arrests to
know what he's going to do if you walk
the streets in New York or on the subway
you can see it coming and you often do
and you have to make it you have to run
or you have to do something it's sad but
they are obvious threats these unstabled
either uh drug addicted or mentally ill
criminals so
the White Marine could be a black Marine
he's still a hero so race has nothing to
do it do with it and the only reason why
I bring it up is because it's going to
be one it will happen because this is so
quote black and white in terms of a case
the guy's a hero they're gonna have to
bring race into this and they're gonna
and and and all of those other crimes
where it's a white you know a white
death and a black suspect uh are never
talked about but this one these kinds
always are because of the fixation on
Race by the media which drives eyeballs
creates and and foments division on
social media that keeps them working
it's exciting it's fun but ultimately
it's damaging and it's I think this is
the I keep saying the Bernie gets moment
but this is a moment where the culture
is up against the wall and you're gonna
have to make a decision about what kind
of City you want or whether you're going
to leave one last point on the way out
and I hate to steal this from you judge
but you said it during a clip earlier
and I found profound and that is when
Jordan Neely's attorney was speaking you
said where were you before there are a
lot of people AOC
Ayanna Presley his family these
attorneys who were not there for Jordan
Neely and life but are certainly ready
and willing to be there for him in the
moment of death hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else